so you don't help me
but advise them on the way to prohibit
are we gonna get to see Lance really
come to terms with losing his daughter
are we gonna see him grieving the whole
rest of the season well obviously it's
not gonna go away overnight is it you
know that that something like that stays
with anybody forevermore doesn't it and
it's a huge loss it's gonna scar him
forever but of course he's got this new
woman in his life and you know as much
as basically in love with Donna smoke
now hilarious you know nothing will ever
replace obvious daughter
laurels always a cornerstone of Lance's
life moral compass and but what is
interesting is the relationship it's
exploring that relationship now between
Donna and Lance in terms of you know
about how that develops and maybe she's
his new Cornerstone new moral compass
and that's been interesting doing that
because you know Lance was terrifying
the idea not just his daughter dying but
dealing with that grief without someone
like her around to get him through that
Donna and Lance are probably the two
most opposite characters on the show but
what is it about their dynamic that you
feel like really works as a couple well
I think I was imagined this first time
that Lance must have seen
Donna and be like what is this Wilma
she's crazy she's out of a mind what is
she wearing I am so attracted to her
y-you know and its side before it she's
such a contrast diner
and she has such a good heart she's got
such a good soul and you know that's
well if all goes to plan according to
what the fans really want and Lance and
Donna get together and Oliver and
Felicity get together you could then be
Oliver's father-in-law now listen here
lad I won't have you running around on
that roof anymore you're gonna sit
inside calm things down I don't know if
time for the quiet life yeah that would
be an interesting scenario in there
you